citizens of the reject Nation Greg here
John how are you I'm curious how are you
I'm good I'm good so I was uh working
out and simultaneously having my car be
a little worked on and then I got blown
up on the phone about did you hear about
the Deadpool 3 news on my way back I was
like John get over here he was running
super duper late and now we're here to
see whatever this announcement is from
Vance City Reynolds let's see what's
going on why don't you go ahead and
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated all right let's do it that's
probably the best I've ever done by the
way around that was great all right
[Music]
hey everyone uh we're extremely sad to
have missed d23 but we've been working
very hard on the next Deadpool film for
uh a good long while now
I've had to really search my soul on
this one his first appearance in the MCU
obviously needs to feel special we need
to stay true to the character uh find
new depth motivation meaning every
Deadpool needs to stand out and stand
apart
it's been an incredible challenge that
has forced me to reach down myself deep
inside
I have nothing
here
just completely
empty up here
and terrifying but we did have one idea
hey Hugh what whoa
uh you cheeky bastard
[Music]
oh [ __ ] make the most of that contract
before it expires
[Music]
yeah Greg Reynolds nine six twenty four
Davis official release date for your
birthday perfect oh my goodness right
after your b day I didn't once I
registered it was Hugh Jackman I didn't
even catch that line what was it hey Hue
Jackman back there yeah oh yeah ah
confirmed confirmed oh yeah man I
remember when Sean Levy was talking
about it um you know I think it was with
Brandon Davis that the like he would
love to try to get Hugh Jackman back and
I was there going if there's anyone who
can get
um Hugh Jackman and Ryan Reynolds the
team up for Deadpool movie I feel like
hey the Friendship of Ryan Reynolds of
course but then also Sean Levy who has
already directed uh Hugh Jackman a
couple of times by this point he's
obviously directed Ryan Reynolds a
couple of times now that I was like yeah
he'd be the perfect director to unite
them and it could probably be the thing
to get them on board and oh my God
Wolverine's returning I know one and the
breadth of possibilities too because you
know it can't just be like like a
one-off cameo like especially if they're
going to make an announcement like this
I would have to imagine Wolverine is
going to be some sort of significant
presence in the movie which is so cool
and also a great way I mean the movie
comes out in 2024 so the whole like
contract thing about using X-Men and you
can't you know recast until 2023 like I
still think it's a great way to pay that
off to like send them off with Wolverine
like the most beloved of all the fox
X-Men portrayal and that is the best way
I feel like for Hugh Jackman to come
back I know a lot of people have been
saying I do it for Avengers Secret Wars
or something like that for like a cami
or whatever but to me Deadpool has been
trying to get Wolverine in there at
least that's like the storyline for
Deadpool one and two that the little
hints and drops and teases it's it would
just be the perfect Deadpool 3 to have
Hugh Jackman involved and for Wolverine
to come back in kind of like a funny way
but with with Ryan Reynolds someone who
he obviously gets along with incredibly
well they love to rib each other in the
jest and all that like this is just
perfect to me oh yeah they'll be a
perfect like Odd Couple in a way like
not in the same comedy yeah absolutely
you know and and think of the
possibilities like I think didn't one at
one point Ryan Reynolds say they want to
make like a buddy Road Trip movie out of
it or something like that like you know
you know it'll be more complex and more
science fiction and more comic book than
that but just the prospect like this
gets your mind going in so many
directions and you know that yeah just
like as cool as it would be to have
Wolverine back for a secret Wars Cameo
or something like this like this is the
ideal I think because we can get
something both substantial but also
something maybe a little more fun and a
little off the beaten path of what we've
seen of Hugh Jackman's Wolverine in the
past yeah and it doesn't have to really
mess with Logan timeline either because
Logan's a little bit further in the
future yeah absolutely so I don't know
what it would be I mean it probably has
to be something that's very like MCU in
in a certain sense but keep it at R
rating you better keep it that our
rating Marvel yeah we want to hear
Wolverine swear but it has to be some
something probably a little bit more MCU
interconnective maybe something
Multiverse connected that way it doesn't
mess with the the Logan continuity or if
they are keeping it within the X-Men
timeline of that fox X-Men franchise
Logan took place a little bit more in
the future and then like further past
Deadpool not that the Deadpool
continuity really matters like time
travel and stuff yeah exactly hop
between the multiverses and everything
like that like it also makes me wonder
if there's going to be any sort of
additional Fox X-Men multiversal hopping
and traveling because Deadpool does
still come from that side of the Marvel
movie conversation so it makes me wonder
yeah who else we could see along the way
too and also Ryan Reynolds I was
watching the interview that Rob I still
don't know say his name Rob McAllen
honey mcculleny when he was taking he
took over uh Jimmy Kimmel guy from It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia the Creator
and plays Mac and you know they were
talking a lot in depth about how uh Ryan
Reynolds loves marketing he loves
marketing and he loves to paint his
story with marketing he loves
commercials and so watching it through
this lens of you know throwing into the
narrative that we didn't participate in
d23 I'm like was it originally part of
the plan to put it in d23 I mean it's a
line that you could easily just throw in
when you're doing a re-recording for a
voiceover uh for a narration in a
commercial sure but I'm like damn if
this had come out at d23 this would
anyone who was like d23 was
disappointing yeah
everything yeah maybe there's a random
time to drop this it's just such a
random time I know it doesn't make much
sense but also maybe as a fan of
marketing you could assume that perhaps
you want to make a splash when
everyone's quiet and not expecting
anything so that you can really grab the
attention and not have to compete for
that or anything and fall is an
interesting release date for it because
the other ones came out as either mayor
I think it was May because that's
usually when the X-Men movies would come
out May is uh like seems like summer
blockbuster time yeah you don't really
hear about like massive releases usually
September's Labor Day weekend ever
Blockbusters I mean I imagine that's
probably Labor Day weekend of 2024. yeah
they want that that Shang Chi Rob Zombie
Halloween box office that's right she
was uh okay yeah that's right never mind
yeah I forgot about that still it's not
a really common thing for like Marvel to
release him am I wrong about that I
don't really remember the actual release
dates of MCU films well you were also in
a different time now where we get way
more releases per year so there's like
one every quarter yeah so it makes sense
to me but you know either way I'm very
excited for this and uh it's something
that I I always had my doubts and I
think I said it in the video when they
were talking about Sean Levy coming back
that if there's anyone who could where I
believe Hugh Jackman could return it
would be more than Avengers it would be
Deadpool three so for this to happen is
like pure fan wish fulfillment at its
finest hour yeah think Aviation
drinks
and thanks uh to Hugh Jackman for
finding only making the schedule work to
shoot this but that's why they couldn't
come to d23 he was just so busy they
couldn't shoot this one simple Pro I
haven't walked in the background
well in the suit too you know it's like
the suit I don't know if that's the suit
they're gonna use in the movie for
Deadpool but it is like all black so I
don't know like that caught my eye too I
know the Wolverine Hugh Jackman's the
main point of this but I was like they
keep using this interesting like dark
suit I wonder if that's a sign of things
to come this is going to be special now
we have something to really anticipates
tune in next week when uh Kevin feige
doesn't say anything because it doesn't
like to anyway guys thanks for being
here all right let's get to it or bye
what do you mean let's get to it bye
[Music]